we're gonna move on to this new evidence
is emerging in the mysterious case of a
missing Connecticut mother
prosecutors say Jennifer dual OSes blood
was found mixed in with her estranged
husband's DNA inside her home he is now
free after posting a half million dollar
bond CTM national correspondent Rica
Duncan is here at Rica good morning good
morning to you foetus doulas and his
group and his girlfriend entered not
guilty pleas yesterday it has been 19
days since Jennifer dualists was last
seen and her disappearance is being
treated as a homicide but her estranged
husband's lawyer says there's no
evidence his client is behind it
innocence defense attorney norm Pat is
said in court Tuesday the case against
his client foetus Doulos is built on
speculation and hysteria as yet there is
no charge of murder I doubt there can be
one based on the evidence that I'm aware
of
do Lowe's and his girlfriend Michelle
Draconis are charged with tampering with
evidence and hindering the prosecution
in relation to the disappearance of
Jennifer doulos a few hours after
entering a not guilty plea Tuesday
Doulos posted $500,000 bond and walked
free still wearing his orange jumpsuit
people are assuming that my client was
involved it's easy to create that
narrative from a limited number of facts
but according to prosecutors there's new
evidence placing doulos in his estranged
wife's home where he has never lived
finish DNA was found in a mixture the
mother of five was reported missing by
friends on May 24th according to an
arrest affidavit when police arrived at
her home they found blood splatter and
evidence of attempts to clean the crime
scene they came to the conclusion a
serious physical assault had occurred
and Jennifer was the suspected victim
we're working on this 24/7 they happen
since the day that Jennifer disappeared
nearly three weeks later the search for
Jennifer now spanning several
Connecticut towns continues the nation
is rallied behind her because she's a
missing mom of five beautiful children
that doesn't mean my clients the villain
Michele Chicanos attorney said yesterday
trakone assumed innocent and given a
fair trial and a new statement Jennifer
Dulles family said her children are safe
but they miss their mother's embrace and
gentle strength and that is who your
thoughts and prayers with are ages 8 to
13 all right Jo Rico thank you